[Musica]
chi di voi da piccolo sognava di essere
un calciatore che la strout a chi invece
una rockstar qualcuno di voi sognava di
essere una principessa un cavaliere
medievale proprio come me una delle
domande più gettonate durante la nostra
crescita è proprio questa cosa vuoi fare
da grande e noi da bambini
sogniamo però non è facile rispondere a
questa domanda né se andiamo alle
elementari e se abbiamo magari già venti
o trent'anni pensate che qualcuno arriva
la fine della sua vita è ancora non lo
sa
e sapete perché così difficile perché
non è questo il punto ci ho messo un po
a scoprirlo ma ho capito che non è
questa la domanda giusta
quando ero piccolo ero davvero grande e
casinista non riusciva a stare fermo un
secondo mi distraevo in continuazione in
qualsiasi modo
faceva impazzire tutti i miei insegnanti
e credo che molti si ricordino di me
ancora oggi penso di essere il loro
incubo
ovviamente chi nun tene nascondervi che
avevo dei voti davvero pessimi pensate
che per arrivare al 6
dovevo uscire a sommare l'ho scritto con
l'orale tutti i professori i miei
compagni di classe pensavo alla che con
me era tutto inutile che non avrai mai
combinato nulla di buono nella mia vita
avevo una voce fuori dal coro che
parlava ed era quella di mia mamma che
mi diceva di non mollare e che un giorno
anche io avrei conquistato le mie stelle
e allora guardava i miei compagni di
classe e sentivo che fa noi qualcosa era
diverso io mi sentivo diverso
il punto è che quando ti senti di verso
la società di persone in generale ti
fanno sentire anche sbagliato come se le
due parole diverso è sbagliato fossero
due sinonimi puoi essere diverso per
tanti motivi perché non pensi come tutti
perché non agisce come tutti perché non
sei come tutti e dire esattamente così
era l'opposto rispetto a tutti per anni
non capivo non capivo perché dovevo
essere io quello diverso quello fuori
poi ho capito come andavano le cose ho
capito che le persone erano salite
comandate da una specie di morbo quello
della mediocrità
ora vi racconto come funziona
tecnicamente lasciamo e veniamo
programmati per la mediocrità la scuola
ci insegna che per essere promossi basta
arrivare ad un mediocre 6 quando andiamo
male in una materia decidiamo in
un'altra cosa succede che ci mandano a
ripetizione per arrivare a quel
benedetto 6 ma nessuno ci dà un maestro
per allenare invece la nostra eccellenza
io questo non l'ho mai capito
secondo voi perché non si può diventare
ancora più bravi in qualcosa in cui si
eccelle già perché nessuno ci allena
diventare dei fuoriclasse e un ultimo
perché perché per tanti estranee
sbagliato scegliere di eccellere in una
cosa soltanto impegnarsi a farla per il
resto della vita e come si raggiunge
l'eccellenza se non così
io da piccolo volevo diventare qualcuno
voleva raggiungere sempre un nuovo
livello
un po come quando giocavo a qualche
videogioco e continuava a raggiungere il
livello successivo
e poi volevo fare il cavaliere io ho
deciso di seguire questo mio sogno fino
in fondo
vivendo anche secondo i principi del
cavaliere io oggi faccio anche giostre
medievali a cavallo proprio come si
faceva nel medioevo
ho deciso di non abbandonare quel sogno
che avevo da bambino
poi però dovuto fare anche qualcosa di
più moderni perché con i miei servigi da
cavaliere non sarei arrivato a fine mese
così ho deciso che sarei diventato un
imprenditore ora gestisco quattro
aziende la più grande delle quali a
oltre 100 dipendenti visto cosa ho fatto
ho preso una decisione e sono diventato
un cavaliere medievale
poi ho preso un'altra decisione e sono
diventato un imprenditore di successo è
una questione di decisioni secondo voi
se avessi deciso di dare ascolto a tutte
quelle persone che pensavano che da
grande non avrei combinato nulla dove
sarai ora interpretare questo ruolo da
cavaliere medievale mi ha insegnato che
se continuiamo a fare quello che abbiamo
sempre fatto continueremo ad ottenere
quello che abbiamo sempre ottenuto
ti meriti di più dalla vita ma non
otterrà mai nulla se non sei disposta
rimboccarti le maniche e lavorare in
maniera diversa sapete come finisce la
storia della volpe e dell'uva che dopo
vari tentativi in cui la volpe prova
invano a prendere quel grappolo se ne va
dicendo che l'uva è acerba proprio come
tutte le persone che non riescono a
raggiungere a prendere a ottenere quello
che desiderano cosa fanno criticano
sminuiscono distruggono quella
determinata cosa
iniziano a trovare scuse non si può fare
è sbagliato non va bene tu non puoi è
acerba
sono queste le parole che usano per
indurti a pensarla proprio come loro e
qui ha due strade o li ascolti o file di
testa tua mi rifaccio la domanda di
prima secondo voi dove potrei essere ora
io se avessi deciso di dare ascolto a
tutte quelle persone che ogni giorno
cercavano di sminuirne che dicevano che
non avrei mai combinato nulla di buono
nella vita di certo non sarei qui con
voi non li dovete mai mai e poi mai
ascoltare quando dicono che qualcosa non
si può fare voi fate la e poi tornate da
quelli che hanno parlato dimostrate che
invece voi l'avete fatta questa è la
differenza fra i molti e i pochi i pochi
hanno sempre quella fame di crescere
sono ossessionati da raggiungere il loro
livello successivo i pochi sono quelli
che vengono ricordati anche a distanza
di millenni perché perché hanno fatto
quello che molti ritenevano impossibile
non sono dei supereroi non solo lavorato
sulla loro mentalità da next level è
fondamentale in tutto questo credere in
noi stessi
certo non si può sapere dove andremo ci
saremo
in cosa riusciremo e in cosa falliremo
ma tutto questo fa parte della vita che
abbiamo precisa responsabilità nei
nostri stessi confronti quello di
cercare la nostra felicità e lottare
ogni giorno per ottenerla sedati ascolta
chi non crede in voi finirete per dare
ragione a quelle voci a quelle persone e
quello che dicono si verificherà è
difficile lo so ma dentro di voi in
mezzo al buio c'è una luce piccolo o
grande che sia che voi avete il dovere
di alimentarla a volte piccola a volte
grande il vostro dovere è quello di
tenerla sempre accesa sono la mente e il
cuore che ci fanno muovere verso il
prossimo livello per ogni next level
della tua vita devi raggiungere un next
level di the next level per il tuo mai
se tu next level per la tua volontà o
l'ex rider per la tenacia un ex level
per esprimere ogni tuo potenziale
sei tu che le termini chi sei e se ti
lasci troppo convincere dagli altri su
qual è la tua identità finisci per
credere di essere un pollo quando invece
sei un'aquila la conosci questa storia
c'era una volta una bellissima aquila
che viveva in un pollaio insieme a delle
galline buongiorno quest'aquila che si
credeva una gallina mentre era intenta a
razzolare con le altre galline guardò in
alto e cosa vide fine non essere più
malato e maestoso molto simile a lei che
volteggiava in alto nel cielo
chi è chiese subito l'aquila ora delle
galline
quella è un'aquila disse la gallina e a
differenza nostra vuole in alto lassù
nel cielo
che bello sarebbe essere come lei anche
se so che non sarà possibile per me è
così l'aquila andò a dormire e non se ne
curò più
pochi giorni dopo la maestosa aquila che
volteggiava nel cielo noto l'aquila nel
pollaio plano e le disse cara sorella
cosa ci fa lì qui a terra viene a volare
in alto nel cielo insieme a me e
l'aquila che si credeva una gallina
rispose ma che dici mai galline non
possiamo volare in alto come te ma che
dici tu
le rispose l'aquila maestosa guardami e
poi specchiati in questa pozzanghera sei
uguale a me
apri le tue ali
e guarda quanto sono grandi
e così questa favola ci insegna che se
non ascoltiamo ciò che ci dicono gli
altri finiremo veramente per crederci
così profondamente da ricondurla la
nostra identità vivendo una vita metà o
con la retromarcia o comunque ottenendo
molto meno da quello che sono le nostre
innate capacità
restiamo nel pollaio quindi quando pensi
ai tuoi sogni quando partì per
realizzarli devi essere come un
cavaliere medievale
abbassa la visiera del tuo elmo e
procedi dritto al galoppo verso le tue
paure colpendo con la lancia il demone
che in the cavalca verso i tuoi
obiettivi è quello che vuoi essere
perché questa vita è breve
i rimpianti non ti portano al tuo
livello successivo
rispetto chi vuole una vita semplice ma
fin da piccolo ho sempre pensato che
avrei voluto vivere una vita
straordinaria
fantastica quella vita che molti pensano
sia impossibile da vivere siete disposti
a fare di tutto per cambiare la vostra
vita soprattutto siete disposti a
credere di essere speciali a impegnarvi
per raggiungere quel livello successivo
ecco la domanda giusta non cosa volete
fare da grandi ma volete giorno dopo
giorno andare al vostro next level e
allora fatelo
[Musica]
sì